crazy story by getting into a giant
fight with uh with your assistant in
your own home I woke up at five thinking
like it feels like someone's looking at
you but I look over and someone's in the
doorway looking at me like it's hand
behind his back hey the alarm went off
he goes yeah they called me he starts
walking at me and I go dude I didn't
even turn on the alarm and he punched me
and I hit the button then he hit me with
a stun gun then I rolled off the bed and
then I slid under my bed and got my
shotgun and I had to turn it was like so
fast within seconds my buddy for three
years and I was gonna have to shoot him
and uh so I called 9-1-1 so I open up
he's not there there's like seven
windows because it's a mansion obviously
and uh and like he could be in any
window with a rock with a gun with a
brick and I'm holding my shotgun and
there's a cop car and he goes like put
it down and I put it down they're
searching the house I go oh well he's
not in the drawers
uh they couldn't find him he got away
and then I had the whole day I had to
sit there going
to try to kill me than that though was
he a good assistant